[Music]
hey folks welcome back to the dark horse
podcast live stream number lambda
upsilon 3.17719
you're scaring the cat away i am scaring
the cat away
it is the q and a segment of the 2021
commemorative edition of dark horse
welcome
that was a mess no that's fine all right
thank god i didn't do that live
our question from the discord this week
is as follows okay
what system would you recommend we use
to replace the current academic peer
review
publishing company gatekeeping system
what would be an improved way of
discerning validity while allowing space
for truly innovative ideas
it's a big question
and uh and you can't just
fix peer review
and publishing system
without fixing the money problem in
science more broadly
i don't think uh and
i would say you know a couple of a
couple of things that come to mind for
me are
publishing does require money
and
uh one of the things that the granting
agencies have is a lot of money and so
to some degree
a sort of pbs slash npr state funded
universities model a little bit for some
for some
publications science publications
might
might be
a possibility i'm not sure it worked
it would work
um
but but otherwise fixing part of the
problem um while not solving the problem
well how do you how do you have the
money in order to do the publishing
doesn't quite get you there
there are two
two other things at different levels of
solution one is
um the idea of peer review isn't
inherently broken the way that it's
instantiated is broken and one of the
problems is that uh the peers uh that
are asked to review individual papers
are all from a very
or all from the specialty of the
original paper
and whereas in for instance hiring in
academic hiring you generally have a
larger committee it's more than three
people but you usually have at least one
person on the committee who is outside
of the domain of the person who's being
hired
and i would think that if it were
possible and it really should be
possible that um just you know playing
with numbers here if in general papers
have three peers
that review a paper
having two of those peers for any given
paper be outside of the immediate domain
of
the person writing the paper and the
subject of the paper uh would keep such
cabals from forming so that you wouldn't
have these like ipad your back you pat
mine oh i'm gonna publish this piece of
crap and then i'm gonna sign off when
they send me your next piece of crap to
sign off on
so that's that's one of the problems
that happens in peer review and that
would be resolved somewhat it would be
harder for scientists to be routinely
asked to review papers and outside of
their immediate domain but frankly would
make people better scientists and better
thinkers and more likely to be a little
bit more generalist in their capacity
and it might be that you would have sort
of you know someone within the domain
um and someone sort of within the
you know sort of layers nested layers of
domain specificity for viewers
and then the other thing i'd say is that
you know plus um the what was that same
for the public library of science which
started i actually looked it up it
started in 2001. you could show my
screen here zach um seems seems to be
making a go of it like they seem to be
doing a good job and um they have a
little timeline here which is which is
interesting i didn't remember that they
had started back in 2001
but they've got a number of initiatives
so it's open source i don't know and i
couldn't tell from a very brief look
here
how it is that they are funding what
they're doing but they have a number of
journals now that are entirely
open access and
um you know for those for for those
people who don't have university
affiliation and who are looking to find
the scientific literature seeing that
something's been published in plos as a
godsend piece you just don't have to
work any harder you can go and you know
that it's going to be openly available
but i don't know very much about what
all their model is
all right two things one i have
suggested the
idea that reviewers should be
at least include people who are outside
of the field tonight the way i've
suggested it is adjacent field and the
idea
my primary concern
yes there's the reciprocity networks
that evolve when people are too close
together
but there's also just the simple fact
that if you can't explain it to the
people in the adjacent field it isn't
any good i'm sorry that's just simply
true i don't care how technical your
field is you need to be able to explain
it to the people one field over at least
yeah right that's just that's the
shallow end of the pool of clarity and
importance
um but
i also think
um
there's something about the question
that signs up for a broken rubric and
it's like well what are we going to do
about the fact that the engine room is
flooding it's like well yes the ship is
sinking the engine room is flooding for
sure and we could talk about how to get
the water out of the goddamn engine room
but we shouldn't focus on replastering
the walls
yeah the engine room might not be the
primary consideration the fact that the
you know the spine of the ship is about
to crack and it's going to plunge to the
bottom of the sea is more to the point
and so the point is look
everything about peer review is broken
starting with the fact that we've now
started mis-educating people with a
system of reciprocity that causes them
not to be very good at understanding
reality and therefore they're not very
good at reviewing papers even when they
aren't corrupt so
the whole thing is stupid and what's
more it's a fiction to begin with right
because the thing is you say peer review
and it's like saying you know the data
are king
right
i mean you are up for empiricism right
you're a real scientist you think the
data are king i follow the science right
and the point is follow the science the
data are king what do the data say
um peer review all of these things are
um trojan horses of one kind or another
and the basic point is look
review by peers is [ __ ] fantastic if
there are in fact any peers which there
aren't always right if something is
sufficiently you know uh ahead of its
time you won't really have peers and you
will have whoever is closest but their
say doesn't tell you whether it's any
good or not the point is peer review
is a phony label for a system in which
work is stolen or killed off behind the
scenes where nobody can prove it
happened right and the point is hey i
want my work reviewed by peers when
there are peers but i want it done in
public where if they behave badly or
they get it wrong it costs them right i
don't want some anonymous system
where people who are my direct
competitors have the right to review my
work and tell an editor whether it
deserves to see the light of day and
then
if i turn out to be right and my
reviewers turn out to be wrong it leaves
no hallmark in the universe where i get
to come back and say by the way the
editors and the reviewers on this paper
turned out to be wrong because the point
is it never made it anywhere now
it is true that some
of this problem is addressed by preprint
servers but even pre-print servers have
requirements and the answer is look
we have enough examples of people who
don't have the relevant credentials who
have absolutely clobbered the confusions
of a field and moved a field way ahead
of where it was we have enough of these
examples that the fact is i don't care
that you're you know a housekeeper in
bangladesh if you have an idea and it
adds predictive power or reduces the
number of things that we have to assume
welcome you're at the top of the field
right and so why would we you know the
whole thing was predicated on the fact
that paper and ink were expensive and
therefore there was a limit to the
number of things that could be published
and therefore you had to figure out
which things were worthy and which
things weren't and the fact is pixels
aren't this way we can afford to publish
it all
i agree with you to a point that's not
the only reason
that is not the only value of editors
and peer reviewed editors peer review
and editors are different um but
the limiting agent was
paper and ankit and is not anymore but
it is still attention
right and so having
having a source that you trust that you
use to say you know what okay
just making up numbers here 80 you know
8 000 papers came out last week and i
know that this journal is the one that
is most likely to have the things in it
that i am going to and so i go to that
journal you know that's just a basic
level thing that you know pretty much
all academics do like okay i'm going to
start with you know that journal and
this one um but and you know and
relatively few i think would be like oh
i'm having this thought in an area that
i've never thought about before i'm just
gonna you know throw that into a
uh
into a search engine and you know a
research search engine and see what pops
out and try to assess what's going on
from you know how how is it that you
sort the wheat and shaft it's something
that i enjoy doing that you enjoy doing
but most academics do not
like to play around it takes a lot more
time yeah but in the in the mess that
isn't something they're already familiar
with yeah but
the disease is so much less severe than
the cure here
right and the number of bits of toxicity
that flow from a system in which yes
well okay we need the editors to curate
which things are worth your attention
and by the way which things you will be
allowed to pay attention to has
everything to do with how well resourced
your university is so if the editors of
this journal decide that this paper is
worthy of attention that your university
can't afford to buy you access to it
then the point is you don't get to have
that attention and that means that
you're going to pay a cost because
you're going to be that much more
hobbled when you go to write your paper
where you try to advance the field i'm
not putting up with this anymore the
fact is
we are talking to an audience on a
platform built around cat videos
right and the point is people can figure
out whether or not they think we're
worth paying attention to and it may not
be that they have to go through every
channel in order to figure out who's
worth paying attention to there is some
natural way in which people who pay
attention to a channel and find
themselves enhanced in the world because
they actually see stuff coming begin to
talk about the fact that hey you know
this weird channel with the wood
paneling in the background right if you
listen to them it actually turns out you
see stuff coming down the pike right
true so we also have cats we also have
well that's true you can't get on
youtube if you don't but but the fact is
all right now everyone's distracted but
the fact is um
this system i agree that there is a
curation problem i do not agree that
anything about the system falsely called
peer review
is the solution to that problem in any
regard i'm all for good editors in fact
the more i encounter good editors which
is now a reasonably rare phenomenon the
more i appreciate them but i want the
good editors without a few good editors
in this last year yes good editor is an
amazing thing good editor is an amazing
thing the ability not to
you know have the job of both writer and
editor where you're trying to wrestle
every sentence into clarity where you
can you know figure out what somebody
who doesn't didn't write the things
reads when they read it in any way it's
a very good thing but
no i think that the system called peer
review is supposed to lure you into the
false sense of security that it's
actually about review by peers when in
fact it's really you know the joke of
course inside of academia
is that it's peer preview right that it
gives your competitors a look at what's
coming down the pike and if your
competitors are happy with you right
they may let it through and they can
then you know
they basically have insider information
on what the field is about to find out
but it only really works for brick and
the wall type science so that you know
what i what i refer to as
science that is predicated on the
foundation of the field being sound and
accurate and exactly you know
predictive of a building that you would
want to live in when it was done and
we're going to put one more brick in
that in that wall and is going to be
according to plan and yes it's new but
um it fits with the overall thing and
the kind of science that um asks whether
or not the foundation you're building on
top of is in fact sound is far less
likely to get through peer review
because the peers are building within
the foundation that you're putting at
risk yeah and i would just also point
out that we have two extremely good
examples in our field of um people who
moved the needle very substantially and
uh you know would be scoffed at by those
who are uh obsessed with impact factors
and peer review right you got darwin and
you got dawkins right dawkins i believe
i would have to go back and look but i
think he's got like two papers from back
when he you know he was tim bergen
student interestingly enough um but
anyway he's got like a couple of papers
on bird behavior and then what he's got
is a stack of books which don't go
through the system that we call peer
review and the fact is there are some
really important ideas in there things
that change the way we view evolution
you know even human evolution and the
point is well they weren't reviewed by
peers well yes they were yeah we
reviewed it out in public we read them
we talked about them we chatted and
assigned them to our students
assign them to our students and the fact
is it's done in a way that is far more
honest and you know
what is his impact factor right who
cares who cares is the answer
um so anyway yes um
the more one experiences period i mean i
suppose if peer review is working for
you if you're one of the ones who's
getting ahead in the field because
you've got insider info i can imagine
you liking it very much right um i would
like to think were i in that position i
would still detest it
but nonetheless it's detestable and we
ought to get over the idea that it is
some
important
thing that is essential to science
because it ain't
good
next question
lots of discussion on the importance of
early treatment for cobot lately we live
in canada
where we can't get most of what is
recommended any suggestions many thanks
what we do without you your punk rock
hell yeah
punk rock yeah i like that um
well well the the easy part is first
yeah there's a bunch of stuff that
they're gonna happen
impossible time preventing you from
getting and so treatment and prophylaxis
are different but um
there are a lot of things i believe
still in the treatment protocols that
are definitely in the prophylaxis
protocols um
d
c
zinc
and then some ionophore quercetin is
widely available uh hydroxychloroquine
is also apparently ionophore like this
is largely it's working by basically
opening up the cells to zinc and that's
increasingly not available even though
it always was um but uh quercetin does
at least some of that job um i think
what is it an acetyl something something
nac yeah um has
been disappearing uh from shelves as
well certainly but it's made off amazon
but it but maybe still available but
those those first four that i mentioned
though d c zinc and quercetin are still
available widely available as far as i
know and um
at the moment
we're taking we and our children are
taking those um
as a kind of just background prophylaxis
against
illness yep um and also they are
understood understood to be effective
against covet so those four
so hold on
uh with respect to d you need to pay
attention to the fact especially up in
canada you are super likely to be
deficient and
the schema that you need to keep in mind
is that were you a
normal healthy hunter-gatherer in the
past you would be exposed to the sun
vitamin d would be produced it would be
absorbed into fat and as times got lean
because it was the off season that fat
in being burned would release the
vitamin d and so you would have this you
know beautifully elegant system for
regulating your vitamin d levels because
you're working at a deficit almost
certainly to begin with
you need to overwhelm
that system there's a lot of good work
on how much you need to overwhelm it but
in other words there's a dose that gets
you to compensate for the deficit that
you're working at and then there's a
maintenance
dose
well i think
if memory serves i think it is suggested
that basically it's maybe impossible but
at least very very very very difficult
to hurt yourself with vitamin d
uh even cases in which people were
routinely being given like 350 times i
think
the rda for it consistently for like two
years
finally started showing up with some
damage which was immediately reversed
upon just losing that you know it was
just an error in
a manufacturer
um and out of a dairy in new england i
think this was um this is a story that
linda benskin reports in her amazing
review it was a derriere it was a
terrier it was it was indeed um
but with regard to thanks man that what
was i going to say about the dairy or
now i got cow butts you were talking
about uh how um difficult it is to
overdose yourself
yeah that's not that's not helping um
so you were going to say
other things about other supplements um
yes i was going to say that
things to keep in mind a things like
d
uh zinc
um sorry you were talking about
something that sounded like a bolus dose
a big
initial dose and i think um what dr
benskin and others have described is
that that's actually really not
recommended that relatively high
um
daily doses
until and unless your d levels are where
they should be and we're not gonna make
any claims about what we think those
should be but there's you know there's
numbers printed in for instance benson's
article um
is a far better route to actually
getting your levels up than a giant dose
and then sort of you know not taking any
more for a week no no no it's a giant
dose and then a normal dose
um but anyway
neither is going to be harmful i don't
think that that is the recommended
approach fair enough nonetheless you're
dealing with a deficit that comes from
northern latitude indoor living things
like this
and you know you can't take care of it
in the winter with the sun the sun
literally never gets high enough in the
sky for you to make vitamin d so you're
definitely doing it through a supplement
but which requires vigilance
um or cod
vigilance or or cod sure um
no
supplement or cod
right
yeah
yes no in in my my first language that
actually would have made more sense but
not in english um
yeah anyway
you can do a lot with things that
they're going to have a very hard time
making scarce as soon as the sun
gets high in the sky again you can make
vitamin d the normal way um and i think
actually this should be altering our
behavior
yeah um
but uh but that does a tremendous amount
with respect to the things that have
become lightning rods with respect to
ivermectin and hydroxychloroquine
um
these things have been dried up and even
the sources that were difficult to get
to but you could get to them have become
difficult even here in the u.s and in
canada it may be all but impossible but
i wouldn't give up hope i think i think
i i heard earlier that it was difficult
for us that people were in canada were
having a hard time
sourcing ibm at least right and the
thing is a that's criminal b it's not
necessary for you to face covid and
um
not be seriously jeopardized by it in
fact vitamin d it appears as highly
protective
so anyway none of this is medical advice
of course but uh but don't give up hope
because
uh
a lot of the sense that you are left
with only their one remedy is fiction
that they have created the number of
tools in the arsenal is many yep
next question you both were extra
cautious in the beginning of the
pandemic but you don't seem to apply the
same level of precautionary principle to
the omicron variant why is that
omicron seems highly transmissible and
not very virulent
i don't think i'm going to remain
cautious on this until we've seen more
what it does because it is possible that
that is an artifact i think it's highly
unlikely that it's an artifact what is
an artifact
the uh
mild disease
artifact of
small sample size that is non-random
right okay yep um
anyway my if i had to guess today i
would bet strongly in the direction of
yeah this is highly transmissible and it
creates mild disease and is effect in
fact something like and you need to be
careful with this but as many people
have now hinted and as we hinted early
on when i said that this might actually
save us from our
insane public health response by virtue
of the fact that people would get mild
disease and walk away with lifelong
immunity or at least very long-lived
immunity and that that would end the
pandemic
effectively the point is this could
function like a contagious vaccine now
some have wondered i've seen this
speculation online could somebody have
created it could there be a white hat
genome hacking
entity out there that has released a
effectively contagious
vaccine
blah blah blah and
i will say if you follow on from the
conversation we had the genome of this
thing is very hard to explain yep now i
can't say that there isn't
some perfectly natural explanation for
the oddity of the phylogenetic position
of this
virus and the very high level of
mutation that it has apparently
undergone so it one part of uh it seems
to suggest that it was frozen in time
and another part seems to suggest that
it has been accelerated in its rate of
change
so could that be the result of somebody
tinkering it sure could now i wonder if
somebody did that right as a thought
experiment it's very interesting
it's hard
the danger of such a thing even if this
was a white hat attempt to save planet
earth from
uh insane public health policy
um
it's pretty scary because the problem is
a contagious vaccine is a vaccine that
will evolve
right and so
maybe it
remains benign and continues to spread
and saves the world just just to be
clear you are hypothesizing that elmer
grant omicron could have been produced
and if it were produced could be it
could have been produced as a form of
quote unquote contagious vaccine so when
you say contagious vaccine that phrase
that you're using is um hypothetically
what omicron could be
acting as right well and somebody you
know so i don't want to say i'm
hypothesizing because that implies that
i believe this to be likely i would just
say formally i know it shouldn't but
people will hear it that way i'm saying
one hypothesis no matter how unlikely or
likely one hypothesis is that somebody
released this for a purpose and given
its dimension given what it seems to do
which is spread really effectively and
not cause very serious disease and
be capable of creating immunity
you know it's possible that somebody
released it doesn't that sound like
exactly what we needed right assuming it
is what we think it could be exactly
what we needed and you know and consider
i've been
you know it hasn't been a full-time
mission at all but i've been looking for
uh reports
you know hysterical perhaps exaggerated
reports or anything really in the
mainstream media about all the deaths or
frankly any debts attributable to
omicron and i've seen like a handful at
most right and so there's a whole lot of
fear-mongering um but
so again long-coveted we don't know
although the less symptomatic the case
the less likely for long-covered
probably and so you know into an
environment in which clearly a lot of
people want us to be very very terrified
of this new variant
and a lot of us you know
bought it whatever that might mean with
delta omicron just seems like
why
why are we supposed to be terrified of
something that if this were the first
thing if this were our introduction to
covid we probably wouldn't even have
noticed right right like no it wouldn't
have a name there would be no public
response at all if you said uh kova
domicron to someone having not been
through the last two years i've been
like what are you that's a new what what
is that right right no one you would not
even notice it and so um it's we are
certainly not trying to hold it to a
different standard it seems to be a very
different thing with regard to um the
parameters that matter right and if it
is what we think it is then uh you know
what was true with delta which is that
probably the best thing that could
happen is a really well-managed case of
delta right which then gives you
permanent immunity now it's possible the
one thing i've heard about omicron that
gives me pause so far
is that there is some evidence and i
don't know that it's any good at all it
could be
that people who had immunity from prior
variants are not necessarily immune to
omicron but that doesn't strike me as
bad news if the evidence that it creates
mild disease in healthy people turns out
to be robust because then even a
breakthrough case that then gives you
durable immunity well if the reverse
isn't true right like if if you know if
having omicron gives you durable
immunity uh to it and to the things that
came before it and to to some degree uh
minor changes to it you know you can
right it won't provide lasting durable
immunity to all possible future changes
evolution doesn't work that way um but
so long as it's not like i don't know if
we're calling the first one alpha but
like original variance plus delta having
had it don't give you um protection
against omicron okay but does having
omicron provide immunity against
originals and delta
i don't know yeah neither i don't i
don't think i don't think it's known i
haven't seen it either
so i just want to fill in one last piece
of the analysis
people need to understand what a uh
attenuated virus vaccine is right an
attenuated virus vaccine is something
that we create in which we take a virus
that is dangerous we attenuate its
disease-causing capacity but we leave it
alive so that it can be injected into
you and it can cause essentially a mild
infection with this
neutered virus and that causes immunity
and this is some of the best immunity
that we can give through vaccines this
is one of the better technologies but it
has one scary phenomenon
which is because it is actually a live
virus it could evolve and do something
you don't expect now these things are
not contagious right when they are
delivered as a technological vaccine the
point is it's infectious but it's not
contagious and
with omicron you have the danger that
this is a contagious thing and it could
therefore
do something weird and so it's hard for
me to imagine even a
white hat hacking operation
actually green lighting such a thing
because the danger is so great even if
the thing that they created is not
dangerous
the danger that it will turn into
something is substantial
but the point is
what omicron seems to be
is
it seems to have the characteristics of
an attenuated virus vaccine
with an additional parameter which is
that it spreads itself and so that's the
sort of if we take the political
dimension out of it and we just say sort
of scientifically this is good or bad
news
i think that's the question that we're
faced with is it has those
characteristics and you could even
imagine if
our public health authorities were not
raging maniacs
one thing they might do is figure out
well okay
did nature just hand us the backbone of
a vaccine that like for example would
not suck and they could take that thing
and they could for example
alter it so that it was no longer
contagious
right and who knows
um
yes
next question
dr peter mccullough stated that one
cannot get coveted 19 twice that is
cannot be reinfected can you elaborate
and confirm thank you both very much
um can't confirm it
can say
the the question is this and i know
because i asked peter myself
the
kind of immunity generated by infection
that is to say natural immunity is
extremely broad and apparently very
long-lived and so
the
game that we are playing with these
current vaccines is a very different
thing and the proxy that we're using for
how immune you are which is whether you
have a an antibody response is a
terrible proxy right because your
antibodies actually ought to die away
and ideally what we want is
t cell-based immunity
right which does not produce antibodies
but anyway
so the question is this you have a small
number of cases in which people who have
natural immunity appear to get coded
are those because their original case of
covid wasn't really covered did they get
a false positive with their original
case they've actually never had covid
and then they get covered the first time
and we say it's a reinfection
is the second case of covet a false
positive is it a mixture of those and if
you got rid of all of the false positive
indications on either first or second
infection would there be anybody left
over who had a healthy immune system and
had had two cases of covet prior to
omicron that's the question peter says
no he says there's no evidence for a
case that does not look like a false
positive of one sort or another
in which somebody was reinfected which
would be a great thing to be able to say
i don't think it's important
even if there are rare cases of
reinfection they are rare cases that
much is very clear at least it would be
lovely if it were clean
i think i i think could it could become
important at least as a
as a political tool and i mean that in
the best sense of the word if it were if
if it were
if it were true and demonstrably so
uh that you really could not get
reinfected um you know including for
instance omicron having had the original
variant
that would that would be huge
um especially since there's a whole lot
of people garbage arguing about like
natural immunity not even being useful
at all which is i mean
they're just making no sense at all
they're not responding to any of the
abundant evidence out there and so the
cleaner the clearer the more absolute
the actual evidence is the better
but i don't expect you know biology
being a complex system i don't expect us
to get something quite so clean and
especially given what you suggested
about omicron maybe being able to evade
natural immunity from various infections
i think there's an even better reason
that clean would be
important which is you know i do
occasionally hear somebody say that
natural immunity ain't all that um which
is obviously a nonsense argument that
doesn't stand up to evidence um
but what does get said which i find
totally diabolical is that what you
really want is super immunity and so if
you've had covet you still need to get
the vaccine well isn't that amazing no
matter what the case is you still need
the vaccine no matter how safe you are
by virtue of being young and healthy no
matter how immune you are by virtue of
having had covid you still need the
vaccine because that's the important
thing is the vaccine right or how much
emerging evidence on original antigenic
sin there might be out there right none
of it nothing nothing you just simply
that no matter what the evidence does
the conclusion of certain people will
always be the same and
so the point is if you really if there
really were no cases
none at all rather than just vanishingly
rare then you could say yeah super
immunity is not a thing if you've had
covered you're done it's just it just
makes it easier but it's i mean it's
like it's like
the kids and how at risk they are and um
and whether or not they need the
vaccines yep um yes there are
some children who have died
and any child's death i think is a
tragedy actually um but
but it's so vanishingly small that the
idea that we should be treating
five-year-olds the same way we treat
year eighty-year-olds uh with regard to
you know fear of this disease and and
treatment is
badly insane the kids are all right but
we're going to vaccinate them anyway
yeah but we're going to fix that
yeah
um
i think so this is written a little bit
tell it
telegraphically to use my advisor
claudius could you report it
telegenically
um i think
these two initial sets of
i think what is said here if you would
put on your glasses you could back me up
here i need my binoculars at this
distance but
is ben shapiro and jordan peterson is
that how you okay ben shapiro and jordan
peterson mentioned this during coffee
shop talk if biological sex were not
real what would be the justification for
transition surgeries
yeah yeah now this this
god this particular argument
set of arguments the trans rights
activists um
are it's just so filled with
inconsistencies and hypocrisy it's
ridiculous um i'm actually working on
final draft hopefully i promise i'm
getting it to you um
if you're watching editor um
a piece on
on issues of trans and non-binary and
you know whether or not sex is real and
gender is real and you know how mutable
they are in mammals and all of this and
yeah if biological sex weren't real then
trans wouldn't be a thing because what
exactly would you be transitioning
between
it doesn't make any sense it's
incoherent as so much in that space is
well you know the joke is on us
completely really is it yeah okay um you
know
antifa and other flavors of anarchists
right
they
make arguments and if you actually
listen to the arguments right it's not
they're not supportive of the thing you
think they're supportive supportive of
they're supportive of destruction right
yeah and you know we saw this after the
election right after the election right
all of the people who turned a blind eye
and let these people get away with the
crazy crap they went through were like
wait what's that sign that says you're
ungovernable and why are you breaking
the windows of the democratic you know
headquarters in portland what do you
mean you hate biden oh my god what right
and the answer is they told you this you
just didn't listen yeah right they they
in fact they were anti-trump they were
anti-everything yes they are proud of
this position listen to them and you
know believe all antifa when they tell
you we're not governable and we intend
to burn down your courthouse right
um but the point is the postmoderns are
the same freaking way yeah right they
are not right that there is no truth and
that it's all about power but they are
right that they are all about power and
that they are going to treat the truth
as a non-entity and they're going to use
whatever arguments make them happy in
that minute that's yeah that's exactly
right and this you know i mean this this
as i've said to you working on this
essay like okay this needs to be a book
um it's far too much for an essay but
you know i understand
um trans and also mostly separately
disorders of sexual development to be
very real and very rare um and somewhat
more common in some in some cultures
often due to some actually understood
biological phenomenon such as a genetic
anomaly
and sometimes not understood as to why
they are more more common in some places
however
the trans rights activists and the um
the
rules now that allow you just declare
yourself the opposite sex and this tends
to go in one direction and not the other
uh you're a man and you declare yourself
a woman and now you go to the top of
women's sports or you get into a women's
prison or you go into a
rape crisis center and you don't even
have to do anything but you know call me
carla and it you know is that a
stereotype yes does it happen yes are
women suffering yes it's bad news and in
the case of the trans rights activists
which again i'm
separating from the actually true trans
people and actually true intersex people
it is about power
it's about power
they are coming for the rights of
women and children and homosexuals all
so hard won over many many years and uh
a large part of society is saying yeah
sure go for it because this must be the
next civil rights battle because you
said it was
since when do we believe the people who
are coming in and abusing people and
making claims about what it is that
they're doing
i embrace all of that but i i missed why
i'm supposed to call you carla
mommy oh okay sorry
that was the dude who wants to start
competing against oh my god to the
prison that makes a lot more sense yeah
no don't call me carla all right i don't
know i don't know where that came from
and i don't know however yeah we know we
know what carl
yeah yeah that's maybe the only one
okay um
we already did this one what are your
thoughts regarding the origin and
evolution of the omicron variant
you at least talked about one
possibility yeah let's put let's put it
this way um
this is actually let me just say if you
get omicron will omicron antibodies
protect against original covet and delta
or just omicron and subsequent uh vocs
variants of concern yeah um our
backwards compatibility so we also
talked about that yeah yeah to know um
it may or may not matter and this
actually um
we might want to have
jay cui straighten us out on this but
there's something confusing about the
way viruses function
in the sense that you have
a swarm
of variants
and so the point is if omicron by virtue
of its
its transmissibility
essentially drives the other variants to
extinction which is what we have seen
with things like delta then the point is
even if it didn't provide immunity to
delta if delta went extinct because
somehow and the swarm thing needs some
explaining it's not straightforward as
far as i'm concerned but
um if
if omicron
provides immunity to things descended
from omicron and the other things the
precursors go extinct by virtue of the
fact that they are competed by omicron
still works yep
okay the question about the
different mechanisms same result
mechanisms being invisible to the human
being or the population experience right
for the most part i'd be much happier if
the answer was it just simply gives you
immunity to everything yeah but even if
it didn't it might be sufficient to
control the thing completely sure
um with respect to the
uh weird fact of omicron in one sense
having
been absent from the world for a period
of time right it appears to be derived
from a strain that disappeared from the
world and then got jump started as if it
was in a freezer that is to say as you
said when we talked about this a few
weeks ago
its closest known relative
is last known from many many months ago
and there are so many changes normally
we would have other intermediate forms
basically yeah and it's given that this
is such a well-tracked virus where all
the intermediate forms or was it in fact
banked and here we go right and we have
two other examples we have the 77 flu
which ultimately was proven to have been
a lab escapee by virtue of the fact that
it had been absent from the world since
i was in 1950 or something like that and
then uh
asar's kobe 2 itself has this it's not
the exact same story but what it is is
it arrives perfectly adapted to infect
human beings without a history of
learning that trick
so anyway we have that sort of uh fact
in the genome here and we also have a
very high number of
variants right
mutations within the genome right so
that tells
you're talking about mutations within
the omicron variant yes okay the omicron
var the omicron variant has many
mutations and appears to have been in
stasis and those two things point in
opposite directions right right so
anyway yes the question is does that
inherently point to somebody
technologically tinkering no
but what you need is
some sort of explanation about how
nature could do that right and so i just
want to point to an analogy
there's an interesting fact if you think
about every phylogeny you've ever seen
every tree of life diagram that you've
seen
right
they
almost always bifurcate right you don't
have a bunch of
branches coming from the same point
unless your data isn't any good unless
the data doesn't tell you how to
organize it right because basically a
species tends to divide into two species
and then one of those species can divide
into two species and so you get this
bifurcation pattern the chance of a
thing simultaneously splitting three
ways or really you know splitting into
two new forms in addition to retaining
its old form are so staggeringly low
that you don't see
what are called polytomies when you have
three or four or five or more branches
coming off a single node um unless in
general
uh it is reflecting a failure of our
understanding of what actually happened
like that is when you see a polytelly on
a tree with three or more um
bifurcations bifurcation points um
branches from a single node that is an
indication that we don't exactly know
what's going on right it's an indication
that we don't have enough data rather
than an indication of biology having
split something into three rather than
two right however yes that is not an
absolute rule there are cases in which
polytomis are created by biological
phenomena for example
there's a famous case in cichlid fishes
in africa in what is it
lake victoria
it's all in all three of them they all
got different um different
characterizations but in the next story
you're going to tell you my
understanding is this and even if this
understanding isn't exactly right it's a
proof of concept of how you could get
something where you would get a
you know many branches coming from the
same point from a biological fact not a
data fact right
and the case that as i understand it
what happens is these lakes
fluctuate in uh depth water level and so
you've got some population of ancestral
cichlids and the thing drops below some
level and what was a lake turns into 50
lakes yeah and the point is so not only
do they fluctuate in depth but the floor
of the lake is highly varied right it's
not just a basin right or at least two
of the rift lakes are highly varied and
so when the water level drops you end up
with a bunch of different lakes as
opposed to just one smaller lake right
you and you know the funny thing is you
get the opposite phenomenon from sea
level change in places like indonesia
where things that look like islands
aren't always islands so anyway these
kinds of phenomena the the lakes in
particular
as the lakes dry up and take a
population that was exchanging genes and
separate it into 50 populations that
temporarily but for a long period of
time aren't then the point is you get
what we call allopatric speciation
that is to say speciation in separated
populations and then the water level
rises they're still different species
and then scientists come along and they
say why are all these different species
in one lake
and the point is an actual ecological
ecological force that is a moment in
time causing something that's more than
a bifurcation right and so my point is
i remember
coming upon that as an explanation for
polytomy and thinking oh okay so you can
get an exotic situation where a polytomy
is not an artifact of your data set it's
actually telling you something about
biology but you need a story and what
what actually took place that caused
this that isn't like the normal story of
speciation and in the case of omicron
there could be some really cool natural
story out there
that explains this crazy was it stuck in
a freezer was it on fast forward kind of
genome
right and it could be awesome i would
love to know that story wouldn't it be i
mean it would have to be marvel coming
up with nothing like right what what
could it be but yeah it'd be amazing but
it'd be
let's put it this way if it's a natural
story it's gonna be a great one right if
it's not a natural story it's going to
be fascinating who who put this together
and why did they mean to release it um
but
anyway i'm i'm all ears
on this one yeah
so like that awesome
um oh
it just it just reordered itself
um coveted comorbidities like hbp is
that gonna be high blood pressure i
think hypertension does it appear to
matter if it is being successfully
treated or if it remains untreated
asking for a friend wait
does it
does it appear to matter if it is being
successfully treated or if it remains
untreated
well boy i think um
specifically with regard to hypertension
i
am not a doctor and have not thought
about this explicitly in a while
but a fairly long time ago near the end
of my father's life i was thinking a lot
about hypertension
uh as he was routinely being told that
his high blood pressure was a big source
of um some of his problems and he had a
lot of other issues as well
and my sense then was that the medical
establishment did not understand not
fully understand blood pressure uh was
again using a single simple metric to
diagnose and describe where you should
be and where you shouldn't be
and that it was not actually clear to me
at all
that in many of the cases where it was
being identified as a problem that it
was
i
also had this
experience um during my pregnancies
which is a story for another time where
i got dosed with pre-eclampsia which is
diagnostic right yeah did i say diagon
you said dost which would be weird yeah
yeah who wouldn't do that
diagnosed with preeclampsia which is a
very very serious condition
when it's real and my sense in both of
the ends of my pregnancies was
no i actually think that being told to
lie down and shut up and not move for
the last six weeks of my pregnancy is
going to be worse for me and i'm not
going to comply and i didn't and i was
fine and so are our children um so you
know the sort of over diagnosis the
looking for simple metrics um is you
know this is this is not a drum beat
that we are new to with covid the idea
that no actually too much of what is
passing for
good health care is in fact very very
bad health care so i i have
i have a suspicion that hypertension is
much more complicated than it seems it
does show up as you saw earlier today on
some of these lists of comorbidities so
i think there is something real there i
think there's a real signal there but i
don't know exactly what it is
yeah i don't have too much to add except
that
one has the sense that this is a complex
factor
and that there may be some component of
that factor that matters a great deal
but that be you know the the category
itself is not all that helpful yeah
um so i don't know i don't know that's a
useful response yeah and i would say
behave proceed with caution yeah i mean
if if we take something else like one of
the other comorbidities um i mean
obesity is the obvious one we've already
talked about it you know like you know
can't you know what would it mean for it
to be successfully treated um
uh or if it remains untreated i think
you know you
you would you would prefer to be lighter
if you you if you are morbidly obese
it's not good for you you can be far
healthier than you might be at the same
weight and far less healthy but um it
will also improve your health if you if
you lose weight
um for i guess for many of the other
comorbidities i'm thinking of you know
what does treatment mean
if the treatment for kidney disease or
diabetes um you know is
medicinal
is drugs that are then going to cause
side effects for which you're going to
need other drugs which are going to
cause side effects etc etc
or
there is either understood by your
doctor or not but understood by some
hopefully savvy long-standing tradition
of treatment that involves you taking
some responsibility into your own hands
and behaving differently either through
your activity or your food or your
exposures
by all means do that
by all means do that no matter what
assume reindeer could fly and had
glowing noses
what evolutionary path and mechanisms
get them there merry christmas and happy
new year to you both
okay i got this one
um what happens you're gonna take the
christmas
christmas question great
it's all you no no
the obvious answer here is uh
that we create a simulation in which
that doesn't violate the rules and
therefore our evolutionary history
are staving off our own extinction long
enough to generate simulators in which
flying reindeer makes some sense is
really the only path
that's a terrible answer it is it's a
terrible terrible answer okay terrible
yeah
well there's actually four questions
here right flying reindeer red-nosed
reindeer um
evolutionary path i'm going to read that
as selective forces and mechanisms okay
for each so flying
flying selection four mechanisms by
which they get there and red nose is
selection form mechanism
selection four yes um that is by which
we get there it's in the song we already
know the selective advantage of of
rudolph's red nose it wasn't rhinitis
so that may be the mechanism
that may be the mechanism but the
selective force yes like what you know
what you know he he was able to light
them having are they so in this in this
rubric uh flying had to come first in in
the order of of character evolution
flying had to come first if they're just
well
yeah i guess if they're on the ground
still the red nose could help shine
shine the way but you know the problem
as well as i do do i yeah
the
the problem is the reindeer has four
limbs
and if you repurpose any of those limbs
for flying then we're talking about the
red nose dude stay on topic
but you said four different questions
you said the flying had to come first
yes but i was saying that had to come
first but once you're on the red nose
just stay on top of the moment then
we'll talk about yes the angel's wings
and all of that okay so that's where
we're going the rhinitis is favored
becomes a symbiont you've assumed the
mechanism is rhinitis no you said that's
the mechanism it's not the selective
force i said that could be the mechanism
i was actually going to say i'm not sure
what the mechanism is okay so let's say
it's rhinitis photo fours in the nose i
don't know
because right now this only makes you
kind of it doesn't make you glow does it
only only some say it close frankly i
i'm not even sure this story is
metaphorically true
they're terrible to live with sometimes
i know just terrible
no appreciation for christmas carols
whatsoever
well i mean okay it's not even a
careless song it's a story it's a song
and one of one of the couple of best
animated christmas
specials right
which one the rudolph the red-nosed
reindeer one
yeah i guess yeah okay
i don't know i like i like the one with
the great pumpkin
like i said
terrible to live with i know that was
charlie brown i think yes and not
christmas i think well yes that true
that too but um
okay
the red nose um gets them back in the
end group and helps the group navigate
um through blizzardy darkness
so that's that's the selective
uh pressure that uh encourages red noses
why
why there's only one i don't know but i
think we're just basically getting a
snapshot of the of the reindeer
landscape and you would expect it to
spread it seems like a valuable
um
pressure also
after the triumph of the red-nosed
reindeer you have the selective
advantage the sexual selective advantage
of having a red nose
and being fond after literally
the girl reindeer yeah and now
it seems to me that some of the names of
santa's other reindeer are somewhat
gender neutral but i think they're kind
of all boys aren't they
oh wait no vixen isn't vixen one
yes i think so that sounds like a great
that really does yeah yeah yeah
i don't know how much further we can go
with that we
we could
delicately
ask the question of whether vixen is a
boy reindeer but is in fact trans and
trans species i think i think it's a
girl fox oh well all right yep
i think you win that round i think i do
too now you were gonna take us down the
road of the flying and whether or not
it's um what the selective forces might
be and how plausible in all of this yeah
my point was going to be
it's homology again isn't it with you
well
no it's really your point i'm just
bringing it forward in time but the
problem with the pegasus
is that it has both wings and four limbs
and so where did the extra pair of
wings the extra limbs come from well
maybe it's there's a
there's a serial homology issue so
you've got a repetition of uh i i always
forget when i'm not thinking about
actively it's the hawks of the homeobox
genes you get a repetition for instance
in the vertebral column that spurs an
additional girdle and an additional
settlement totally segmented being limbs
now it's wings this would be a lot
better if it was rudolph the flying
centipede
rather than reindeer i mean yes
drosophila are the most studied the the
fruit flies in the most study with
regard to the um serial homology and the
and the repetition in these
in these genes but we have them too i
mean our our vertebral column is uh is
has extended we think uh as a result of
uh repetitions in these um again i don't
remember if it's homeobox or hox genes
but
uh one being a subcategory of the other
what um
were it possible yes
what would have been the original
selective pressure for uh wings and
wings while retaining full
quadrupedality
quadrupedality uh i think it's uh the
pressure of the market to generate a
flying self-illuminating
survey that
i think this question is so far outside
my area of expertise that i'm in fact
doing nothing other than damaging my
credibility
trying to i think unfortunately in some
circles you are now enhancing it oh is
that right
odd yes
um okay so i don't know this next one
you should take a look at it's just a
comment i don't know if i should read it
you can't you're pretending to look but
i know you can't see yeah i need the
binocular glasses yeah so that one
um
this one
oh sorry this one here
okay okay sure um
lammon seems a lost cause sam harris
recently suggested listening to dr
mccullough would cause brain damage uh
can he be reached canada school boards
are now pushing for vaccinated
five-year-olds they're they've done most
of the teens
um i heard something i didn't uh
i heard something in sam's most recent
podcast that surprised me a little bit
which was i heard sam uh
working in the direction of steel
manning the other side and
frankly sam if you're listening i hope
you'll take this in the
spirit in which it is offered i thought
you did a terrible job of steel manning
the other side but i was greatly
heartened to hear you try and
if that means that you are
beginning to investigate why it is that
people that you once respected have come
to a completely different conclusion
than you
and you're willing to entertain the
possibility that we have not lost our
minds i think you'll find that there is
a lot um to be
discovered and engaged and i know that
we would welcome you back here on what i
believe is the side of reason
so anyway uh
happy new year to you
all right um i think we're at about an
hour
uh that let's do three more
shall we yeah
as a self-published author i'm curious
to know how you went about choosing a
publishing company in an age of
censorship and cancel culture
it's an interesting question and i don't
think that we are um at uh
uh we don't have the freedom to say all
of what happened
um
but we were thrilled to just just as we
were actually finishing the proposal
um and our our wonderful
agent howard
yoon was going to beginning was was
beginning was about to begin
um shopping it around to the big
publishers
and you know he and we had had a lot of
conversations about about exactly this
issue we were approached uh by our our
ex who turned out to be our excellent
editor helen at um at penguin
and um specifically helen healy and she
specifically came and i have to align
some details here um with um the idea of
there being an imprint which didn't did
not end up manifesting
that was specifically going to be
created
to deal with the increasing levels of
censorship and
and cancel culture within
within publishing both in academia and
not this of course not being an academic
book and so the idea was uh i don't know
if you're thinking of writing a book or
what book you might be wanting to write
but given who you are you might be at
risk of um having the the
counselors come at you
including from within house whatever
publishing house you go with
and i come effectively with an offer of
a potential imprint that would
specifically protect against that and so
that was intriguing
even though it didn't end up manifesting
yes but still we were not re-cancelled
not not well we're not not recanceled
for the book
other other things you never know but
yeah
well the attempts were made yes attempts
were attempts were made
all right
vaccines are likened to an airbag in a
car despite personal risk stratification
the airbag will protect you do you agree
let's put it this way um the more i
learn about shenanigans
the less interested i am to hear what
the conclusion of those analyses was
because none of it looks honest and if
you don't know what i'm talking about
there is a very interesting piece of
work
that is now
twitter is clearly suppressing the
hashtag
but the work goes under the hashtag of
more harm than good done by a canadian
outfit that analyzed the pfizer trials
and
there is also there's a pdf version
which might be a little
dry there's also a video version
which runs through the same context
that's in the pdf
and i think everybody
ought to just simply go through it right
and the point is this is the kind of
analysis that results in the conclusion
that um
the vaccines are you know yes doing an
awful lot of good here and maybe doing
too much harm over there and shouldn't
we be risk stratifying the question is
you know what can we actually
objectively say about the value of them
in either controlling the disease or
protecting individual health and i'm not
saying they don't but i am saying my
confidence that i can say that they do
some good and that we can see it in an
age stratified thing i have lost all
confidence that i know the research is
so compromised so repeatedly by so many
obvious games
that i don't believe we know
we can't we don't know enough to make
policy around these things other than
it's not worth it
one more comment before the final
question the comment is
lefty says bureaucratic capture the
righty says normal inevitable please
grow up i love you too
um
i think uh those of us
the evolutionary biologists on the left
who see what humans are and have been
and can be
will say uh
we therefore need a system that
uh
precludes the gaming of the system
because yes people will figure out ways
to
get what they personally want even if
they started out in a system where they
thought they were working for a higher
good
i agree with that i will say i am
actually working on an essay that talks
about this very issue and it actually
comes from
an insight i had years ago when
game b was actually people meeting in a
room talking about how to make
civilization work
and
the answer is the right is not incorrect
that this is
normal for this to happen in fact that's
why the evolutionary biologists are
saying what they're saying which is
that thing is going to evolve and the
question is
that is not the same thing as saying
there is nothing to do about it but what
you do about it has to be evolutionarily
aware or it won't work and so the
question is what is the evolutionarily
aware
mechanism that frustrates the evolution
of capture and it did not work here and
it
we need to bootstrap it yeah
okay last question
uh
last question for today
do groups of human beings sacrifice or
exile unwanted members in lean times
well the go-to person on this would be
renee gerard
this is a name you will increasingly
hear there is some sort of there's some
quadrant of the library that is the
antidote of the quadrant of the library
that we are being dragged into that has
you know in its fiction part kafka and
orwell and heller and and uh
all of that and um
and huxley uh and in its non-fiction
part has a searching you know amongst
tuskegee and brown shirts and all of
these other several of the books that i
shared last week
yeah so that quadrant of the library
what we are forced to think about in
order to understand our current moment
there's also an antidote quadrant of the
library that we ought to be searching
and it contains things like
mass formation and rene gerard's
work on scapegoating which is really
what you're getting at here
um
yes but that i mean that's all true i
guess i expected you to go to the maya
and um specifically speak to um what was
your hypothesis and what we wrote into
our book
um about
the building the
the the policy of having public works
projects
uh that can expand
in times of plenty and that then can be
put on hold without forcing anyone to
starve or
going after individuals in particular uh
in lean times
basically does an end run around what
seems to be yes a fairly general
truth
that in lean times
some people will end up suffering and it
is likely that uh some some group will
look around and decide who it is that
they're going to go after first and
we'll go after them
beautiful and i think in some sense what
i would say is i hope that our book
lodges itself in that part of the
library for exactly this reason and that
the answer is there are things that one
can do you need to understand what the
phenomena are why they happen
oh in the so imagine a library with two
wings over in the you know kafka orwell
[Music]
tuskegee mangala part of the library
witch hunting belongs solidly in there
and then in this antidote
wing of the library you have
um you have gerard and you have
mass formation and hopefully you have
our book and our argument about the maya
and what it is that they imply
uh and you know the question is all
right which side of the library are we
going to hang out on are we going to
keep being dragged over here to problem
nightmare space or are we going to get
over here to solution space and figure
out how one actually addresses this so
that we don't keep re
revisiting the the ugly part yeah let's
be like the maya let's build some
pyramids hell yeah and some stock bays
stock based too yeah to get between the
pyramids exactly city states all right
yeah i mean thanks makes me miss them
indeed yeah we have some friends who are
in maya country right now and uh
i wish we were with them yep yeah
that brings us to the end of
q a number 109
we've been at this a while we have been
we've been at this for a while not just
in in across months and now years um but
today so
um
thank you as always uh we are really
heartened it is hard to be heartened
these days but we are heartened by how
much we hear from how many of you uh
with regard to man we got some letters
this week we also got some gifts to our
p.o box
um some books uh that are amazing and
we've just begun to dip into and um
and also some other gifts including some
letters
explaining
how
something about people's lives and how
they come to
how they came to find us and it means a
lot we really we really thank you for
that very much
so in this in this end of year um merry
christmas to everyone and happy new year
and i think we'll be up we'll be back
before the
before the new year but um we will not
be back on christmas and
anything else before yeah i was going to
say
happy hanukkah afterglow merry christmas
happy new year
uh and uh
this is gonna be an interesting year but
i think it's gonna be a decisive one and
let's figure out how to
how to be bold fight courageously and
get back to
being uh americans and citizens of the
world and uh and being good to each
other indeed now and always
be good to the ones you love eat good
food and get outside be well everyone
[Music]
you